le reste en france on trouve encore le
conflit de la navigation aérienne les
conversations hier n'ont rien donné en
fin de soirée c'était même la rupture la
rupture entre les compagnies aériennes
et les syndicats de navigants une
rupture laquelle assistaient edwards
lors sider hélas que cela tous les
aspects d'une rupture
oui est ce que vous envisagez la reprise
des vols eh bien nous allons reprendre
nos belles avec ceux de nos navigant qui
accepteront les conditions et les
modalités que nous avions proposée en
dernier dieu comme vous le savez un
nombre important d'entre eux n'ont pas
désapprouvé ces propositions puisqu'au
total la moitié seulement des navigants
français avaient suivi les syndicats
dans leur position est ce que pour vous
il ya une rupture des négociations
bien oui nous pensons qu'il ya rupture
de négociations oui
la direction envisage de faire voler les
navigants qui ont accepté ces
propositions lors du dernier référendum
est-ce que pensez vous que c'est
possible bien c'est évidemment possible
mais enfin il est difficile de
déterminer quels sont ceux qui ont voté
pour ou contre puisque c'est un vote
secret vous l'avez compris il se
pourrait qu'il y ait donc des vols au
début de la semaine prochaine on ne peut
avoir absolument aucune aucune idée du
pourcentage de navigants qui serait
justement à suivre les propositions de
la direction des compagnies air